on a donc la Communauté économique des
États de l'Afrique de l'Ouest la CEDEAO
qui ne peut pas accepter un coup d'État
au Niger des questions de vie
démocratique c'est un coup d'État qui
concerne les autorités nigériennes dans
lesquelles la France n'est pas
intervenue dans lesquelles les pays
extraordinaires ne sont pas intervenus
c'est un coup d'État qui typiquement
n'engage que le président et la garde
présidentielle dans le centre d'acteurs
nigériens donc
nigérien ne peut pas accepter que ce
coup d’état prospère que ce serait une
très mauvaise indication pour l'ensemble
des autres pays de la zone donc elle a
deux leviers pour essayer de faire
reculer les puccistes un une action
militaire on voit qu'aujourd'hui vous
l'avez dit il y a pas de consensus fort
sur Taxe militaire mais il pourrait
venir dans les dans les jours qui
viennent et il y a surtout les
conséquences et les sanctions
économiques qui pèsent énormément sur la
population au nigérienne c'est très
difficile de trouver de l'argent les
prix ont augmenté de 10 15 même 50% pour
l'huile par exemple donc ça pèse
énormément et autres dimensions on a des
putschistes qui sont pas très homogènes
dans leur façon leurs intérêts sont pas
les mêmes les programmes sont pas les
mêmes le m62 par exemple n'a pas le même
programme même si la rejoint aujourd'hui
les puccins
oui tout à fait mais
attendez qui qui voudrait comprendre la
situation le but du but donc je termine
c'est une fiche à savoir mais ces
intérêts personnels le bout du peuple le
but du putsch ces intérêts personnels du
des différents acteurs qui sont encore
dans l'ombre car les acteurs importants
ne sont pas encore sortis du général le
tiani qui a fait le coup d'État qui
était mis sur la touche donc
qui sont des du président Issoufou qui
est président précédent qui continue à
être contrôler le Niger tout en ayant
voilà donc c'est ça c'est le jeu
d'intérêt purement personnel au Niger et
donc le temps ce que je veux dire par là
c'est que le temps ne joue pas forcément
pour les putschistes qui ne sont pas
homogènes que ne peut plus la Sion qui
commence à souffrir et moi je suis allé
deux fois récemment il n'y avait pas
comme au Mali ou en Guinée de mouvement
de rue la population nigerienne était
plutôt satisfaite des conditions de vie
et de l'évolution du pays donc on n'est
pas du tout la même configuration que la
Guinée ou le Mali avec un coup d'État
qui est purement personnel donc ça veut
dire c'est le drapeau qui est on est
dans la rue par les opinions publiques
par une partie d'opinion publique parce
que il y a beaucoup de
personnes
de la France mais ce que l'on voit là
est souvent des manifestations qui sont
assez téléguidées parfois orienté etc ça
empêche pas qu'il y a un sentiment
anti-français mais pas forcément de
cette violence là moi je vois de deux
hypothèses la première c'est que la CDO
arrive à faire le travail de négociation
et puis
aux Américains de rentrer maintenant
dans la dans la négociation pour peser
un peu sur l'équilibre entre les
différentes forces nigériennes si c'est
pas le cas les puces vont s'installer et
il y aura certainement dans les semaines
qui viennent soit un deuxième soit
un rééquilibrage parce que les hommes
qui pèsent aujourd'hui à Niger ne sont
pas visibles aujourd'hui dans dans le
putsch actuel on les voit pas en
première ligne alors ces hommes par
exemple les chinois ils entendent très
peu ils viennent de ils sont construits
pour 2 milliards et demi de pipeline les
Chinois et il y a une société qui va
exploiter le pétrole nigérien en 2024
dont la Constitution vient d'être
finalisée et ça c'est des éléments
d'intérêt financier qui à mon avis
doivent rentrer dans le putsch très
clairement très clairement il y a des
intérêts financiers qui ont sur lesquels
mais certainement qui ont été nature non
mais à faire influencer les puces pour
chinois est-ce que ça on est dans la
certitude est-ce que nos services par
exemple les services français l'ont vu
ont alerté
[Musique]
plus de puissance ou influence étrangère
d'un intérêt à laisser les djihadistes
arrivés à Niamey mais les armées
maliennes les armées burkinabè et
l'armée nigériane même si elle s'est
renforcée sous la sous le président
Bazoum ne sont pas suffisamment armés
suffisamment aguerris pour faire face au
terrorisme et on le voit déjà à la
frontière la frontière entre le Niger et
le Mali aujourd'hui est très très flou
et c'est djihadistes qui contrôle cette
partie là et ça va prospérer ça c'est ce
qui va se passer dans les mois qui
viennent alors qui a intérêt à
intervenir à faire en sorte que ça ne
dégénère pas et qu'on mette en place des
cordons sanitaires pour protéger le
Niger et pour ça il faut garder les
Américains qui ont mis l'homme à Gadès
il faut garder une partie des armées
européennes allemands italiens etc qui
sécurisent le Niger il y a très très peu
d'attentats au Niger comparé au Mali et
à Burkina Faso
les Nigériens
ont intérêts et ce qui va se passer s'il
y a pas d'accord très rapidement avec
les putschistes c'est qu'une partie du
nord du Niger tous les nomades vont
commencer à se rebeller et vouloir
refaire ces sessions parce que ils sont
pas du tout d'accord avec ce qui se
passe à Niamey et donc ils vont
revendiquer une partition du du du du
Niger c'est une éventualité également et
c'est au nord bizarrement qui a une
grande partie des richesses pétrolifères
et